[Music]
[Music]
if you're having tea with a giant hello
kitty doll
then you're almost certainly in japan
[Music]
this is a place that specializes
in obsessing over things
and taking every want and need to their
unnatural extreme
if you desire a refreshing drink
there's a vending machine that will
evaluate your face
and pick the perfect beverage
[Music]
or perhaps you prefer to imbibe
while in the company of an ornamental
owl
[Music]
or to down a latte with a
three-dimensional robot
as garnish
ah that's a good robot
the japanese of course also fetishized
technology
like no other culture
[Music]
japan's once glorious tech shine may
have dulled with the decline of sony
and other empires but
without question there's a new tech
movement
on the rise
[Music]
i'm traveling from tokyo to kyoto
to meet the japanese inventors bringing
this new culture to life
away we go along the way
i'll hang with some robots it can kick
my ass
and lose myself in this trippy
wonderland
all on this episode of hello world
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet
making things that will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them
[Music]
where else would i begin my journey but
in tokyo
millions of people make their way around
the city in an orderly fashion
[Music]
doing their best not to bother anyone
the hustle of modern life dominates the
city
but it's at night that tokyo really
comes to life
welcome to the robot restaurant
[Music]
as touristy and insane as all of this is
it actually gets to the heart of japan's
relationship with robots
[Music]
the machines here come with stories and
personality
they're good they're bad and sometimes
they eat people
but far away from the fire-breathing
dinosaurs
and werewolf guitarists
researchers at a tokyo museum have set
up a workshop
where they're looking to prove that
robots can be imbued with life
hello eat your red pill
and try to keep up
[Music]
professor takashi ikegami has helped
create this thing
which looks like it comes straight from
ex machina central casting
through a series of sensors and
artificial intelligence software
this android looks out into the world
and reacts to what it sees
the android is in effect evolving based
on what its ai software
seems to like basically there are two
different
mechanisms one is um autonomous
algorithm generators okay it's coupled
with each other
also there's artificial neural networks
spontaneously
firing and sending signals to each other
[Music]
as someone approaches the android the
sensors detect the movement
and then the software kicks in to
determine how the robot will move in
response
[Music]
but for the moment it has a movement
style that could be described
as that really drunk guy at the party
okay so in each one of these sensor
boxes
right here yes there's two cameras yep
and this is measuring the measuring the
distance yes so when i
come closer or further away from the
machine
then robot has to do something it has to
do react to that yeah
you guys will add more and more sensors
yeah you can put like temperature
sensors
sound sensors many other sensors
armed with more sensors the robot can
make more judgments about its
environment
and more nuanced reactions
over time the movements and gurgles
change
the thinking is that the robot will
eventually form its own personality
and possibly even language
what's the deal with the noise is it
hungry
this sound is designed by my student
that behavior is modifying those sounds
the sound is changing all the time
it's more like you know a primitive
language that's i think the interesting
part of it
like our babies we don't have to tell
everything to the baby but baby can
learn
unconsciously by interacting with people
with the environment right
[Music]
once we have a bunch of lifelike systems
around us
maybe our concept of what is life will
be very much different
and then if we want to coexist with
robots
then we maybe have to learn different
languages
different way of thinking
[Music]
so that doesn't freak you out you think
that's
i think it's much more ideal to me
comparing with
this you know very violent world right
now
[Music]
well thank you for letting me see your
android thank you
thank you oh she said something
i think he said he likes you
[Music]
[Applause]
if you want to learn about robot culture
kyoto is as good of a place to start as
any
for hundreds of years it has been the
showcase city
for japan's most famous traditions from
geishas to spectacular temples
over in the university district you can
also find
some of japan's best technological minds
i've come to doshisha university to dive
deep
into japan's love affair with robots
with a professor
and one of japan's most active robot
[Music]
hobbyists
[Music]
wow yeah akira's got good moves
embodies a japanese concept known as
otaku
it refers to a person who obsesses over
something
be it hello kitty sushi or robots
for takashi robotics is more than a
hobby
it's his passion most of his free time
goes into assembling these things by
hand
out of 3d printed body parts and
electronics
do you work on these almost every day
yes
about two hours almost every day
that's cool
each one takes months to build including
the software for the choreographed moves
but it's not all for show these robots
must fight
to earn their key akira would hit other
robots
one of takashi's robots recently took
first place in a competition
making him king of the otaku
[Music]
and when you're the king there are
people that want to study you
one of japan's foremost researchers into
the relationship between man
and bots is hirofumi katsuno an
anthropologist
here at toshisha university i was
looking for you know the passionate
people who work on robots
i joined the group and started uh to
create my own robots
and youtube met at these in the events
hiro felt compelled to ask that
seinfeldian
question what's the deal with japan and
all those robots
it's related to japan's sort of national
quest
to establish its own identity
after the world war ii
so after the sort of devastation of the
whole land
japan started to rebuild the nation
through promoting the peaceful use of
science and technology
in that process i think many uh anime
creators and manga creators
started to ponder the kind of ideal
relationship between the japanese and
technology
for instance like tisca some
hiro is not alone in pointing to the
significance of astro boy
the manga series started in the 1950s
and has a mad scientist type building an
android to replace his dead son
the saga goes on to explore what life
would be like
if humans and robots coexist
and it's that very same idea that one
local tech giant
has invested millions of dollars to
pursue
[Music]
[Laughter]
hitachi produces a shocking amount of
stuff
from brain scanners right on up to
nuclear reactors
this being japan it's also in the robot
game
i've gone to one of the company's
vaunted research labs to see its latest
take on the robot that people desire
most
an autonomous helper hitachi calls this
creature
[Music]
emu
hello everyone
i'm very happy to meet you emu was
developed as a sort of friendly robot
concierge
equipped with ai for navigation and
speech recognition
he might provide directions at an
airport or do some low-level security
work
or he might be kicked over by a cynical
reporter
looking for a good time
that's pretty cool that resemblance
between emu and my pal
hello kitty is on purpose emu's designer
asi baba wanted the robot to have the
same
harmless non-creepy feel is it meant to
look
like a child yes because everyone
like it everyone likes child yeah fair
enough
there's an adorable quality to these
robots and they may be helpful one day
for the moment though rolling around
looking cute
is about the extent of what they can do
and they're super expensive to make
do you have a price that you're aiming
to get to we replied to
you know cheaper car
be cheaper than a car come okay
what's that emu you want to make up for
your failings by showing me an
autonomous vehicle
okay
thanks heavier here's my ride
this sweet hog with the flip top door
is called ropitz
away we go
it's sort of like a self-driving car but
is meant to travel down
sidewalks instead of on the road
and this is the vehicle's inventor ryoki
hichonosis
japan's aging population has forced the
country
to try and invent new ways to help
seniors make their way around
cities the idea here is that someone can
summon the car to their house
and then go for a leisurely drive to the
store
the open windows and slow speed of
ropets means that the driver can even
have a chat with a friend
or perhaps an emmy walking nearby
[Applause]
it's a beautiful utopian future hitachi
is imagining for us
all full of smart compassionate robots
attending to our every need
but suffice it to say that future very
much remains
the future the wall the wall the wall
where are we going where are we going
what's going on robot helping
you
japan's creative thinking has stalled in
recent years
as its tech giants and startups have
struggled
[Music]
to find out why i joined my friend
noriaki okubo
back in tokyo for a chat about japan's
tech scene
over noodles
aki is a well-connected tech guru
venture capitalist
and champion noodle slurper
i've never worked on my slurp technique
after a week in japan
i had so many questions for him how
would you compare
the japanese vc scene to say
silicon valley traditional vcs are
really
bad because they don't want to take
risks
there's a lot of new vcs that are doing
pretty well new
internet companies and you know they can
take risk but not the traditional
you know salaryman type vcs
[Music]
when aki says salary man he's talking
about that image we have
of the conservative hard-working
japanese businessman
this culture rewards conformity and safe
business decisions
according to aki it's a key factor in
the fall of japan's tech dominance
in favor of the disruptive mentality of
silicon valley
the decisions that come up from that
kind of process
is always going to be you know let's
just do something that's
okay and nothing cool yeah is there a
big call to change
that way of thinking i mean i think
there is but it's just
still very the minority yeah
walaki's take on technology here holds
true in the big picture
there are plenty of people and companies
that see themselves as
rebels trying to buck the system
and no one exemplifies this better than
toshiyuki onoko
and his company team lab
for inoco struck
when he was just eight years old
[Music]
in my second year of junior high i
usually tell people that an electric
wave
struck me i'm not sure what it actually
was
or even how to describe this but a
strong sense of duty that i needed to do
something that had meaning
in society suddenly came over me
if that red pill is still circulating
through your system
then this will feel perfect let's see if
we can go
find a fish
[Music]
it's one of team labs world famous
techno art experiences
they use this projection mapping
technology
to track the fish
when they hit somebody's body supposed
to turn into a flower
all right we're supposed to move on
let's go down the hallway how long does
it take to do one of these
projects not forever
we take one idea and create reconsider
then repeat the process
[Music]
for example the exhibit you saw crystal
universe
we've been working on for five years the
pool one
we've been working on for two to three
years
team lab has around 400 employees
thinking up new ever weirder things
and working in their makeshift
laboratories what's this one
[Music]
you're making clothes right i think it's
for a show
it's for a dancer no he's making clothes
for
a mascot here
we're experimenting with a device that
allows you to manipulate
waves in the water you're gonna make
patterns in the water
and control the patterns yeah that's
cool
[Music]
this is the inoko is known throughout
japan as a flamboyant character
for him you either create something new
where you grow old and stay quiet
[Music]
japanese society has aged too much
it is a society of old people it's
conservative
and it can't seek value in new things so
you're trying to change that
no no no no no no no
no i want to be with people who want to
take a step
into the new world people who are
creative
who want to change the world these
people
i hope to inspire to have an influence
on
or by having them experience our art
i want to shake their values so rather
than taking on people who don't want
change
i work to inspire people who want change
[Music]
it's a noco and the people wired like
him the two seem to be japan's best hope
for a major technology resurgence
the well-funded robotics labs and
corporate giants
do amazing research but they've
struggled to keep pace with places like
silicon valley
and china when it comes to making
products that actually reach consumers
japan remains trapped between two worlds
the old and the new
it's a country that has turned the
future into a religion
but that must still deal with an aging
population
and rigid customs the way forward for
japan
its chance to really make a mark will
almost certainly come from its robots
emu for one is already getting ready to
be a guide
and chauffeur at the 2020 olympics
for now i say good night to japan
may all our dreams be filled with hello
kitty
[Music]
up next on hello world i head to russia
to fly drones in siberia hang with a
techno oligarch
wow it's really cool and get beaten with
a birch branch